yeah I'm not familiar with uh whether or
not you had a relationship with Dolph or
whether or not it was good or bad but
obviously losing him for the City of
Memphis was a big deal
um for hip-hop in general
um what what was the you know the the
severity of that loss just for the scene
out there man
I mean like I said I was incarcerated
when it happened right so I could I
didn't really just feel that fake I just
knew it was [ __ ] up damn like
like damn like you know what I'm saying
but I never got the full effect
you know what I'm saying because but now
that I'm out here and I'm like damn no
dope
you know what I'm saying but you know
when it comes to death I embrace death
like that's on some personal [ __ ] that's
a whole nother conversation but I don't
look at death too bad like I embrace it
like it is what it is
yeah I mean I feel like two if you live
a certain way you kind of got to brace
yourself for death yeah at all times and
not just if you live a certain way it
could be anybody not to knock on wood
but you can even have a rig right it's
written and whatever's gonna happen
gonna happen all you can do is try to
prevent it the best way you can but when
it's your time it's your time you can't
run from it it's one thing you can't run
from you can't run from it so when it
comes to them like I ain't the one to
just be like uh because I I'm a really
like I understand it gotta happen
a guy and I know it's a conversation
that [ __ ] don't like to help
but yeah
I ain't gonna lie to myself that's fair
man